are we ruled by midwit the people in
charge are more stupid than you
basically and this is from mackelli in
one of his books the first method for
estimating the intelligence of a ruler
is to look at the men he has around him
if we look at the men and women around
our contemporary rulers what do we find
few reasons for optimism in 2011 the
Royal statistical Society asked 97
British MPS a simple maths question if
you spin a coin twice what is the
probability of getting two heads since
the chance of getting a heads on one
spin is 50% and two spins are
independent the answer is just 50% * 50%
25% not exactly quantum physics
shockingly only 40% of MPS got the
answer right among labor MPS it was only
23% most of those who got the answer
wrong said 50% which is obviously
incorrect when you think about it so it
just reminds us the people who are in
charge are more stupid than you are and
the bar is set unbelievably low